sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation en association avec télé 78
une émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg voici le sommaire
de ce nouveau numéro les pères
fondateurs de l'europe nous vous
parlerons de paul henri spaak l'un des
premiers hommes politiques avoir eu une
vision de coopération européenne
je recevrai l'eurodéputé stéphane bijoux
pour évoquer avec lui la stratégie
européenne pour les régions ultra ma
voix y avait dans l'assiette le chef
renaud ramamurthy nous présentera une
recette d'origine arménienne celle des
paiements les superstitions en europe
evelyne keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire pourquoi le
chiffre 17 fait-il trembler les italiens
c'est ce que nous verrons à la fin de
cette émission mais avant que fait
l'europe dans notre région un exemple
tout de suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
[Musique]
je me trouve aujourd'hui dans la commune
de base non dans les yvelines on a
environ 40 kilomètres de paris je suis
là pour venir voir à biner la gérante de
mes produits d'hygiène et alentour avec
son camion itinérant elles seront dans
les villages ruraux du département pour
proposer des produits locaux aux
habitants
[Musique]
on peut m'expliquer l'histoire de ce
petit camion alors en fait ce petit
camion il a été pensé il ya déjà
maintenant trois ans et demi je dirais
moi j'habitais en fait j'ai grandi dans
ce village là ici à base d'eau et je
venais avec mama mignon fait faire les
courses le mercredi après-midi et donc
c'est quelque chose que j'ai voulu
recréer dans ces villages là où qu'ils
ont sont au final abandonnée par les
commerces et voilà pour redonner un
petit peu de vies et apporter du coût
des denrées alimentaires sur place paul
bass camion ce sont uniquement des
produits locaux a dit ne travaille
qu'avec des producteurs des yvelines où
des départements limitrophes
effectivement c'est que la production
locale donc ils viennent essentiellement
après j'ai quelques producteurs sont au
bord des yvelines donc un petit pas en
normandie un petit peu dans le 92 en
traite ça dépend voilà ce que moi il
faut il faut bien trouver un petit peu
partout mais ça reste vraiment du coup
de l'extra locale je fais pas plus de
pas plus de 100 kilomètres pour aller
même encore temps tu mettes cette norme
je dirais même 50 kilomètres pour aller
chercher les produits si elle dit ne
peut se rendre dans les villages les
plus ruraux du département des yvelines
c'est grâce à ce camion est ce camion il
a été financé en partie grâce à des
fonds européens ça m'a aidé du coût à
l'achat du camion parce que c'est vrai
que forcément on passe par un
financement bancaire il ya beaucoup de
règles dans les seins dans les dossiers
et tout ça est donc mois l'aide
a surtout permis à subventionner la
partie frigo du camion parce qu'il ne
financerait pas toute la partie roulante
donc du coup c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
trois mille deux cents euros de fonds
européens parce que sur la partie frigo
c'était forcément pas la partie la plus
importante de financement au niveau du
tennis
en europe
comme chaque semaine nous vous faisons
découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction européenne
aujourd'hui paul henri spaak ce belge
venait au 19ème siècle est l'un des
premiers hommes à avoir eu une vision de
coopération européenne son parcours avec
europe direct et la maison de l'europe
paul henri spaak est née le 25 janvier
1899 à sheikh big bruxelles en 1916 paul
henri spaak âgé de 17 ans se porte
volontaire de guerre mais il est arrêté
par les allemands en tentant de passer
en territoire libre et chimie la guerre
dans un camp de prisonniers
après des études de droit il se dirige
vers une carrière d'avocat au barreau de
bruxelles il commence sa carrière
politique en belgique en 1932 où il
occupe de nombreux postes ministériels y
compris la politique étrangère avec la
seconde guerre mondiale il est contraint
de rejoindre l'angleterre et devient
membre du gouvernement belge exilé à
londres où il fait campagne pour une
alliance de l'europe occidentale après
la guerre à partir de 1941 il fut l'un
des promoteurs d'une union douanière
entre la belgique les pays bas et le
luxembourg d'où sont sortis les pays du
benelux en 1944 et dans une moindre
mesure la communauté européenne ce pack
s'est fait connaître grâce à sa présence
sur la scène internationale il a été le
premier président de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies puis de
nouveau ministre et chef du gouvernement
belge de 1946 à 1949 et secrétaire
général de l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord otan il est à nouveau
ministre des affaires étrangères et
rejoint le mouvement européen fondé en
1948 par des pionniers européens tels
que winston churchill conrad adenauer et
alcide de gasperi le mouvement rassemble
des personnalités politiques et penseurs
qui veulent construire et préserver
l'europe ancrer la belgique dans le camp
des grandes puissances occidentales en
formant une alliance entre la france et
la grande-bretagne et en l'intégrant à
l'otan
il préside l'assemblée consultative du
conseil de l'europe de 1949 à 1951 où il
défend le plan schuman il démissionne
après que la grande bretagne le refuse
il continuera de défendre l'approbation
de la communauté européenne de défense
c'est od à la chambre des représentants
belges sa vision de l'europe etc en
créant des liens contractuels entre les
pays la paix serait maintenu ils luttent
activement pour la création de la ceca
et d'un marché commun il est cependant
contre une union politique confédérale à
laquelle il préfère une supra
nationalité des institutions paul henri
spaak a joué un rôle essentiel dans la
négociation du traité de rome et la
fondation de la communauté économique
européenne cee
en 1965 il s'attache à résoudre la crise
ouverte par la décision française de ne
plus être membre du conseil crise de la
chaise vide provoqué par charles de
gaulle il se retire de la vie politique
en 1966 est mort le 31 juillet 1972 à
bruxelles son engagement pour la
construction européenne lui vaut le
surnom de monsieur roch il est considéré
comme l'un des pères de l'europe une
aile du parlement européen de bruxelles
portent son nom
sonne robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui stéphane bijoux
eurodéputés membres du groupe renault
europe et président de la délégation à
la commission parlementaire cariforum
-bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
l'auteur du rapport intitulé vers un
renforcement du partenariat avec les
régions ultra périphériques de l'union
alors avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet je rappelle que vous êtes né à
saint denis à la réunion et je voudrais
savoir comment on a le sentiment d'être
européen quand on est si éloignées du
vieux continent alors pour être éloigné
ça c'est sûr qu'on est éloigné 9000
kilomètres de bruxelles de strasbourg
sur cette île de la réunion je vais vous
dire moi j'ai grandi sur un territoire
extraordinaire où le dimanche matin je
pouvais me lever en entendant les
pétards du jour de l'an chinois
leçon de l'église catholique à la messe
à 10 heures des tambours tamouls l'après
midi et le soir l'appel à la mosquée
tout ça dans la même journée et je vais
vous dire cette diversité cette capacité
de vivre ensemble finalement fait qu'il
y a un lien naturel entre ce que nous
sommes profondément et l'adn de l'europe
et ce slogan cette devise européenne
unie dans la diversité
alors je peux vous dire que quand on est
sur une île au milieu de l'océan indien
entre madagascar et l'île maurice et que
vous êtes ce que vous êtes fort de cet
héritage du métissage et que vous avez
la possibilité à la fois d'être créole
réunionnais français et européens je
réponds à votre question en disant que
ce qui prédomine c'est de façon légitime
un sentiment de grande fierté très bien
alors on va s'intéresser à ces régions
ultrapériphériques il faut savoir elles
sont rattachées à trois états membres
l'espagne pour les canaries le portugal
pour les açores et madère et bien sûr la
france pour la réunion vous le disais
vous disiez mais aussi mayotte la
guadeloupe la martinique et saint martin
ça représente plus de 4,8 millions
d'habitants de quelle manière l'union
européenne et l'europe apporte son aide
à ces territoires ultramarins au
quotidien de quelle manière est elle
présentée est ce que sur place on voit
une présence de l'europe au quotidien
alors on partage d'abord cette
citoyenneté
pn et on partage cette volonté de
construire ensemble chacun de nos
territoires et on est dans le cadre d'un
partenariat aux finalement il faut qu'on
soit gagnant-gagnant ça permet des
territoires d'outre-mer permettent à
leurs oeufs ces 5 millions de personnes
dont vous parliez exactement répartis
sur trois océans permettent
effectivement à l'europe de rayonner à
l'international et en même temps
l'europe mise sur nos territoires en
investissant 13 milliards d'euros pour
les fonds de cohésion pour nos pêcheurs
pour nos agriculteurs pour construire
des lycées pour financer des programmes
de formation pour notre jeunesse ce sont
des choses extrêmement fondamental et
bien évidemment ce qui est important
c'est cet investissement qui est fait
sur l'environnement sur l'écologie
puisque la nature même de nos
territoires qui sont majoritairement des
îles sauf la guyane mais qui est sur le
continent amazonien avec cette forêt
amazonienne et bien les investissements
de l'europe pour l'écologie à un moment
où on investit dans le green deal sont
des choses fondamentales alors en
préambule de votre rapport je le disais
tout à l'heure vous soulignez plusieurs
points ce soir en terme de biodiversité
de dimension marine de maritime de
risque de pollution le taux d'abandon
scolaire vous parliez de construire des
lycées
est ce que ces régions qui font une
richesse pour l'europe sont aussi à
surveiller pour pas qu'il y ait ce un
sentiment finalement d'appartenance
uniquement à son territoire ultramarin
alors il ya d'abord une réalité qui est
celle de l'espace qui est le nôtre et
les régions ultra périphériques de
l'europe on apporte une surface maritime
qui permet à l'europe d'être la deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale 25 millions
de kilomètres carrés imaginer c'est une
plus grand comme deux fois la superficie
de la de la russie c'est énorme et ça
pose les choses d'abord en termes de
responsabilité une responsabilité qui
est la nôtre vis-à-vis de la
biodiversité les outre-mers abrite 80 %
de la biodiversité européenne et quand
on sait que
ucn tire les experts tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant attention on est en
train de perdre déjà un tiers de nos
plans de nos animaux de nos végétaux il
y à une urgence à agir et agir vite sur
chacun de ces territoires pour ce qui
est de la cohésion et de ce pari sur la
jeunesse ce qui nous caractérise
outre mer ce sont ces le potentiel de
nos jeunes à mayotte par exemple une
personne sur deux a moins de 18 ans ce
n'est pas du tout le cas sur le vieux
continent mais exactement et quand vous
avez cette réalité là vous avez d'abord
une responsabilité qui est celle de
trouver des solutions pour ouvrir
l'horizon de nos jeunes mois chez moi
l'île de la réunion quand je croise des
jeunes puisque je suis systématiquement
sur le terrain à la rencontre et à
l'écouté de no fun il m'a dit mais
monsieur le député en créole août
l'horizon les cas c'est notre horizon
est cassé et quand vous êtes face à des
jeunes qui n'ont pas de perspective est
bien votre responsabilité c'est de
construire des solutions et l'europe est
un partenaire efficace aux côtés de la
volonté du gouvernement français de
construire des solutions pour les
outremers vous parliez de changement qui
est de changement climatique est-ce que
vous pensez que le tourisme durable
parce que le tourisme c'est finalement
un des grands pans de l'économie de ces
territoires est ce que le tourisme
durable doit être une priorité pour ces
régions alors c'est plus qu'une priorité
je vais vous dire il y a une légitimité
à miser sur les outre mer pour
construire moi un tourisme durable moi
je réclame ici au parlement européen la
création d'un label tourisme durable
élire soir j'ai dit au commissaire
thierry breton mais miser sur nous misez
sur les outre mer pourquoi parce que
comme nous sommes en première ligne du
dérèglement climatique
nous construisons des solutions pour
effectivement avoir un autre mode de
fonctionnement un nouveau modèle de
développement basé sur cette
réconciliation nécessaire entre
l'économie et l'écologie et le tourisme
est un périmètre sur lequel on peut
construire des solutions durables en
polynésie française par exemple on est
capable aujourd'hui de climatisé des
hôtels en allant puiser l'eau froide au
fond des océans sans produire du gaz
néfastes pour l'environnement on est
capable aujourd'hui dans nos territoires
de construire des offres où on peut
trouver cette réconciliation cette
capacité à vivre en harmonie avec la
nature parce que nous sommes ce que nous
sommes et parce que nous donnons les
moyens avec l'europe avec le
gouvernement de créer des solutions
concrètes merci beaucoup stéphane bijoux
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputés membres du groupe
renault europe président de la
délégation la commission parlementaire
kari kari forum e et je rappelle à
l'adresse de la plate forme future eu
une pointe europa.eu si vous souhaitez
donner votre avis sur l'avenir de l'euro
zone europe voyage
voyage et dans l'assiette cette semaine
renault ramamurthy le chef du restaurant
petrossian a paris nous présente une
recette d'origine arménienne salut
enchanté je m'appelle renault ramamurthy
je suis le chef du restaurant petrossian
paris 7e aujourd'hui on va réaliser une
recette
typique arménienne les menti alors pour
faire cette recette on va avoir besoin
de deux éléments donc une pâte et la
farce donc pour la pâte on va avoir
besoin de 250 g de farine t55 deux ans
qui est bio un peu d'eau du sel est un
peu de farine pour pouvoir travailler la
pâte et en second plan on va avoir
besoin de persil frais l'équivalent
d'une botte 400 g de
de boeuf alors j'ai pris du la macreuse
c'est une viande de troisième catégorie
en fait qui est du monde à s'étendre et
qu'il tient là circuits sont donc vu
concéder radium qui vont cuire environ
30 minutes donc du coup on a besoin
d'avoir une
une viande qui supporte la cuisson la
haute cuisson et pour finir des oignons
et un peu d'assaisonnement on a réfléchi
cette recette avec une telle petrossian
en fait c'est une recette que sa
grand-mère lui faisait quand il était
plus jeune et on a retravaillé cette
recette donc voilà j'essaie de la
remettre un peu au goût du jour en
allégeant un peu quelques quelques
éléments notamment sur la pâte et aussi
la farce voilà partir sur une face à un
peu moins grasses et alléger la pâte en
neuf donc on essaie de retravailler 7,7
recettes emblématiques
lesbo alors du coup on va commencer par
la pâte alors aujourd'hui j'utilise un
robot coupe mais on peut très bien le
faire à la main la maison
au batteur utilisent l'euro beaucoup
parce que voilà c'est un gain de temps
on fait vraiment des grosses quantités
au restaurant donc on va commencer par
la farine ensuite on a fait une belle
pincée de sel ensuite on va directement
casser nos 2 e
il faut avoir incorporé les yeux on va
travailler la pâte donc vraiment laissé
tête à plat et assez importante en fait
on va incorporer les les oeufs dans la
farine
donc là on peut remarquer qu'on a
vraiment on commence à voir un short de
sablage avec la pac donc là ça m'a
vraiment les autres comment ça c'est
encore corps et ça c'est nickel ça a
apporté une bonne texture à la pâte la
tension a pas trop trop travailler ça
bat donc là je veux remettre un tout
petit coup de rouge beaucoup pour
pouvoir un peu avoir une pâte homogène
voilà vous pouvez le voir c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ça bleus
voilà cette étape là en fait on va
ajouter un peu d'eau pour importer de
l'humidité est aussi avoir une pâte
homogène
voilà après avoir travailler la pâte
pendant environ une minute donc on
constate qu'on a commencé à voir une
belle belle boule qui est nickel c'est
un peu humide après avoir travailler la
pâte pendant environ une minute je
prends un peu de farine je ferai mon
poste flore et c'est le fait de mettre
un peu de farine sur son poste ensuite
je veux récupérer ma patte
voilà je légèrement la flore
là je viens là travailler avec la plus
de la main pour la porter un peu de
l'élasticité mais pas trop
donc la fraise la pâte un peu comme on
pourrait friser une pâte une pâte brisée
à la maison donc voilà là on a une super
belle patte hyper homogène
vous avez bien vu c'est hyper rapide
c'est vraiment ça prend cinq minutes
c'est génial comme recette c'est assez
simple donc là c'est parti on va laisser
reposer la pâte pendant environ 30
minutes
alors let's go c'est parti deuxième
étape la farce donc du coup on va à chez
tous nos éléments donc là moi j'utilise
un robot un robot hachoir
combiné à mon batteur mais à la maison
on peut faire si on peut faire ça aussi
à la main qu'on a le temps nous on
attendait qu'on n'a pas souvent le temps
de cuisiner autant se faciliter la tâche
donc on va commencer par les oignons
ensuite après avoir haché les oignons on
va tout de suite mettre le persil
montcoal perso je suis pas embêtés à
l'effeuiller au contraire je veux garder
un peu de tiges c'est vraiment ce qui va
apporter ce côté arbas et à la pâte et
on va finir par
la viande
voilà pour voilà pour la farce vous avez
vu c'est très simple on a juste à chez
tous nos éléments si jamais vous n'avez
pas de hachoir à la maison vous pouvez
très bien aussi demander à votre boucher
de vous acheter la viande en avance et
on peut tailler les oignons à la main et
le persil à la main donc ensuite on va
assaisonner cette farce
poivre
mon pauvre du moulin fraîchement moulu
ça s'est vraiment bien pour les parcs
faut pas hésiter à poivre et cette farce
voilà on a très peu d'éléments c'est
assez simple à faire ça demande un peu
de temps mais au final ensuite quand
manger un monde si je peux vous dire que
on a envie d'y retourner
ensuite on n'hésite pas à y aller avec
la main ce qui est bien en fait en
cuisine mêmes danseurs de recettes c'est
que c'était une familiale donc on y va
avec la main
c'est agréable de sentir la farce on
voit qu'elle est une très belle texture
les brillantes il ya un bon équilibre
entre les l'oignon le persil la viande
passé on est vraiment pas mal donc voilà
pour la farce on va les laisser de côté
on va passer au façonnage de notre patte
alors notre petite patte au bout d'une
demi heure de repos il en est où
elle a bien reposé elle est nickel on va
pouvoir l'état les
appareils comme tout à l'heure on va
venir fleuret son poste de travail avec
un peu de farine pouvoir travailler la
pâte donc là on va la diviser
donc là aujourd'hui je vous montre cette
technique à l'aide d'un ami noir
pareil qui est équipé son robot ça peut
être aussi étalé avec un laminoir manuel
donc le but du jeu c'est vraiment
d'étaler la pâte vraiment comme comme si
c'était de la soie
donc là voilà on a vraiment une patte
kir
qui est elle un tel du velours c'est
vraiment de la soie on peut même voir ma
main transparence
on n'est pas trop trop mal à cette étape
en fait on va venir avec d'un couteau
on commence la partie la plus minutieuse
et de l'orfèvrerie
la fameuse étape du façonnage démenti
mais donne vraiment envie cette farce
même cru on a envie de la manger
donc là je prends une petite cuillère à
café
et je vais venir disposer mafart sauce
au milieu des des petits carrés de pâte
donc voilà n'a pas atteint vous avez
bien lu c'est super sympa en fait c'est
une sorte de pâte à lasagnes
c'est un travail un peu méticuleux
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi de vous
présenter cette recette car c'est
vraiment un plat en fait emblématique de
la cuisine arménienne
c'est un plat de portage
simple la famille assez assez simple à
faire donc là ensuite on prend le petit
carré dans ses mains et on va venir
pincer les deux extrémités
de façon à avoir une sorte de petite
barque
[Musique]
voilà on les a bien arrangé c'est
important de bien les rangées en fait
pour la cuisson donc là ils sont c'est
pas mal c'est joli ensuite on va prendre
un peu d'huile végétale
pour apporter la matière grasse
mais les j'ai vraiment ces huit ça va
porter le croustillant doivent être
aussi un tout petit peu de beurre donc
là
j'ai mis du beurre j'ai je met du beurre
clarifié donc du beurre clarifié sa à
bord qu'on fait fondre et en fait on
sait par le petit lait
de la matière grasse donc après avoir
une autre grâce dans la poêle on va
mettre démenti à 170° pendant trente
mille x
[Musique]
après 30 minutes de cuisson voir
ensemble au monde 6
je pense qu'on est pas mal donc la
normandie son fils avait trente minutes
à 170° tout de suite une fois que la la
poêle est encore bien chaude ou votre
plat au four va venir déglacer avec
intel sont blancs
ensuite on va prendre très malade qu'on
va disposer
un peu partout dont le plat ensuite on
apprendre le sumak donc du coup le soma
qui est une épice emblématique d'arménie
qui est vraiment porté sur l'acidité en
iran par semaine au départ tout ça c'est
vraiment votre convenance
aujourd'hui j'avais des beaux moments
des oiseaux donc du coup je dispose est
un peu de un peu de verdure sur ses
ventes y
voilà ça il ya un contraste de couleurs
qui est assez joli voilà on a notre pas
fini de menti donc vous pouvez voir
c'est vraiment coloré
s'appelle vraiment à venir goûter selon
le faire d'ailleurs tout de suite
sévèrement
saône robe sûr sensation
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux chiffres 17 très près de chez nous
il ya des italiens il se moque du
chiffre 13 c'est le chiffre 17 et le
chiffre 10 est écrit en chiffres romains
donc si on le lit dans un sens ça va
faire vie si j'ai vécu donc sous entendu
je suis mort donc pour éviter je suis
mort on va avoir peur du chiffre 17 et
il n'y aura jamais de place 17 sur un
vol alitalia de même qu' il n'y aura pas
de chambre 17 dans un hôtel italien et
on retrouve la superstition lié aux
chiffres traîne dans les salles de
cinéma pas de salies cette
caisse qui a encore dans les étages des
tours dit cette porte malheur
et la couleur qui va selon lui offrir là
qui va se lire c'est que l'on redoute le
vert et eux c'est lequel donc on a beau
être voisins on attribue tous les mêmes
traditions
le violet faut pas arriver habillés en
violet noces sept rebelles
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine bonne soirée à toutes et à
tous
soon europe / sensations
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france